BARBARA IMPERIALI: So
we're going to get started.
This is a complicated
lecture to choreograph,
but I'm going to do my very,
very best because I think
there's some pretty
amazing stuff
that we have to explain that
is carried out in nature.
And one of those things is
how do we replicate the entire
genome of organisms in one
fell swoop almost perfectly--
sometimes there
are little errors--
and fast.
So we're going to refer to
these numbers in a moment.
But first of all, I just
want to get you back
in the picture of where we were
at the end of the last section,
the biochemistry section.
And in the next
few classes we're
going to address issues
related to the central dogma
and the use of nucleic acids
for information storage
and information transfer.
And before I do
that, I just want
to highlight a couple of
things, just some terms
that you should recall and recap
from the biochemistry section
about nucleic acids.
So nucleic acids form
complementary double strands
through base pairing,
and that base pairing
involves hydrogen bonding
between the nucleobases,
one purine to one pyrimidine,
and the AT base pair
is worth two hydrogen bonds.
The GC base pair is worth
three hydrogen bonds.
And those are actually
pretty useful facts
to remember because they
tell us about the stability
of double-stranded DNA, where
it's easier to tease it apart,
and other characteristics.
So it's kind of a useful
thing to keep in mind.
So the base pairing
between what--
the purine pyrimidine pair,
which sets the exact register,
down the double-stranded DNA.
The backbone is the
exact distance apart
because you always
combine a small pyrimidine
with a much larger purine.
So that's something you
should feel comfortable about.
The components are organized in
an anti-parallel orientation,
so one end runs 5
prime to 3 prime.
The other end runs
3 prime to 5 prime.
And I showed you
last time an image
that allows us to
state quite clearly
that the anti-parallel
orientation is significantly
more stable than the
parallel orientation
because you can't make all
those great hydrogen bonds well
in the parallel
organization apart
from everything else
that becomes complicated.
Another important
thing that you're
going to have to remember,
especially in this lecture,
is that we add new
nucleotides to the 3
prime end of a nucleic acid.
And so I'm just going to put
this little guy in the corner
here.
This is the ribose sugar.
That would be where the
nucleobase is attached.
And it's a deoxy
sugar, so there's
no substituent at that carbon.
This is the one position where
the base is. the 2 position,
where it's deoxy,
the 3 position.
And these are all prime numbers.
Remember, the sugars
have prime numbers.
The bases themselves have
numbers without primes
to distinguish what
we're talking about.
So 3, 4, 5, and
they're all prime.
And when we grow the
single strand of DNA,
we always add new basis
to the 3 prime end.
That's an important
numbering system.
I don't like that
piece of chalk.
So we always grow from
5 prime to 3 prime.
And that will be
important to you
as we go through the
discussion today.
And then finally, a feature
of double-stranded DNA,
quite unlike proteins,
which sometimes you'll
thermally or with pH
melt out and will often
have a problem reforming their
reliable structure because
instead of the structure
refolding, they aggregate.
Double-stranded DNA
doesn't aggregate
because it's got all the
negative charges that
would be quite repulsive.
So it would be very
difficult for DNA strands
to aggregate as
such because there's
too much of a concentration
of negative charges.
That would be repulsion
amongst the same type charges.
So DNA can be peeled
apart with heat,
and it will reanneal
faithfully to its partner
a complementary strand.
Once you get to six,
seven, eight base pairs,
that is a nice interaction
between the strands,
and it forms faithfully.
If we have a mistake
in the strands,
the stability of the double
strand will be a bit less,
and we can measure that
through physical measurements
that we carry out in the lab.
So we can measure
the denaturation
or the thermal melt temperature.
So we call this
process, after you
separate double-stranded
DNA, we call it reannealing,
or it's also designated
as hybridization
to form a hybrid, which is
the composite of the two
structures.
Those terms are used
fairly interchangeably.
All right.
So the goals in the
next four classes
are to show you how the
structures of the nucleic acids
really are purposed for
the sorts of processes
that they undergo.
So the replication of
DNA, the conversion
of a strand of DNA into
complementary messenger
RNA once the process
of protein synthesis
needs to be initiated,
that second step.
The first step is
called replication.
The second step, when you
transcribe DNA into RNA,
is called transcription.
And then finally, when you
translate messenger RNA
into proteins.
So going to a
completely new language,
we call it a translation.
And that's the basis
of these lectures.
There is a little bit of
stuff in these lectures
about more complicated issues
in the mammalian cell, where
we have to process the
messenger RNA a bit
before we can have
it leave the nucleus.
And I'll explain at
the time when it comes.
So this is the lineup
for the four lectures.
All right.
Well, I already talked
to you how when you add--
I mentioned it over here--
when you add cytidine
triphosphate, GTP, ATP, TTP,
these are the
activated nucleobases,
so they're the deoxy
nucleoside triphosphates.
They are nucleotides because
they include phosphate,
but when we describe
them, we'll call
them nucleoside
triphosphates if we're going
to mention the phosphate part.
I know that probably doesn't
make any sense at all.
Is everyone OK with that?
If you're just generically
describing something
with a phosphate in it,
you call it a nucleotide.
If you want to be a
little bit more specific,
you say nucleoside, and then
you say how many phosphates.
All right?
And so for the building blocks,
it's a nucleoside triphosphate.
And believe me, I get
that wrong all the time,
and my students correct me.
So I don't have a
problem if you're not
perfect with that nomenclature.
So these are the building blocks
for DNA, for polymerization.
And I just showed you how you
grow from the 5 prime end--
that number's not shown there,
but it's shown over here--
and you add to the 3 prime end.
And the convention,
remember, when
we describe a strand of DNA,
because we make it 5 prime
to 3 prime, we write
it 5 prime to 3 prime
just so that we're
all consistent
and we know what
we're talking about.
Now I want to talk about
two experiments that
enlist the use of isotopes
because these were quite useful
early on to describe some of the
characteristics of replication,
so some of the details of
replication, and also the fact
that DNA was the
genetic material.
So isotopes are
elements that share
the same number of
protons and electrons,
but they differ in the
number of neutrons.
So the common isotopes
of the elements
that are in all the covalent
structures of the body
are hydrogen,
carbon, and what I'm
putting as the number next
to it is the common isotope,
so that number designates the
sum of the number of neutrons
and protons.
So carbon-12, phosphorus-31.
I should have put nitrogen here.
Let's see.
Wait a minute.
I'm going to put these in order
because it makes more sense.
Phosphorus-31, nitrogen-14,
PS, phosphorus-31, and sulfur.
What's the sulfur isotope?
32.
So these are the
common isotopes that
comprise the majority of those
elements within the body.
But there are lots
of experiments
done that have different
isotopes of these atoms
that we can use as
traces or markers, kind
of the same thing.
But you'll see when I mention
the word tracer, to me,
it brings up the radioactive
isotopes because we
use very little of them.
So when we talk
about these elements,
there are different isotopes
that we use commonly.
There's the hydrogen that
has an extra neutron.
That's also called deuterium.
And then there's the
hydrogen that is radioactive.
It's metastable.
It will decay and emit
a radioactive particle.
So this one, we would
call it the heavy isotope,
and this one we would call
the radioactive isotope.
So we could trace certain
hydrogens in biomolecules
by either making those
hydrogens the heavier ones,
or making them the
radioactive ones.
Carbon also has useful isotopes.
Carbon-13 is the heavy
isotope and carbon-14
is the radioactive isotope.
So they're used quite commonly.
And then things get a little
bit different for nitrogen.
We use a heavy isotope of
nitrogen, which is N-15, just
one extra neutron.
But while there is a
radioactive isotope of nitrogen,
it's too short of a half-life
to work within the lab.
It's not useful to us, so
we never talk about it.
But I will describe
to you an experiment
with the heavy N-15 when
we talk about the mechanism
of replication.
And then for
phosphorus and sulfur,
the most important
ones are P-32,
which is a radioactive
phosphorus,
and S-35, which is a
radioactive sulfur.
There is another radioactive
phosphorus that's P-33.
Has a slightly longer half life.
It's kind of handy
to work with if you
have certain experiments.
The half-lives vary a lot, but
the half-life of tritium C-14
are long.
That's why we do carbon dating.
The half-lives of P-32 are
short, less daytime frame,
and sulfur 35 is a
little bit longer.
But those are nuances that
you don't need to worry about.
Now how are these
isotopes useful
as traces and markers to tell
us about biology and details
of biology?
So what I'm going to
just show you here
is a particular
experiment that's
carried out with what
are known as baculovirus.
So viruses infect
eukaryotic cells.
Baculoviruses infect bacteria.
So there's a commonality there.
And when baculoviruses infect
bacteria, just as the parallel
with eukaryotic cells,
they deposit material
into the bacteria so
they can replicate,
so they can hijack the bacteria
to make new baculoviruses.
So an early experiment
was done to ask
what is the genetic material
that transfers the information
from the baculovirus
to the bacterial cell
in order to make
more baculovirus.
So they were able to
demonstrate, in this Hershey
and Chase experiment,
that you could
label protein and DNA
with particular isotopes
and find out what part
of the baculovirus
was important for
transferring information
for the production
of new baculovirus.
So they wanted to label
the capsid protein,
so the proteinaceous
material that's
on the outside of
this lunar lander.
This is a baculovirus.
It's sort of amazing
how it looks.
So they wanted to
label the protein.
But they also wanted
to label the contents
of the baculovirus, the DNA,
with tracer radioisotopes.
So what would be
the best isotopes
to use if you wanted to
differentiate between protein
and nucleic acid?
And what you want
to think about is,
what does protein have that
nucleic acids don't have,
and what do nucleic acids
have that proteins don't have?
Which are the elements that are
important for differentiating?
Yeah.
Over there.
AUDIENCE: Phosphorus.
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Yes, phosphorus.
Do you want to give a
little bit more of a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: OK.
So the answer is
we'd use phosphorus
to label nucleic acids because
that phosphodiester backbone is
rich in phosphorus.
There are a few
phosphates in proteins,
but they're very transient.
They're part of signaling.
But every nucleotide
has a phosphorus
in every building block.
And then in proteins,
they have sulfur in them
where nucleic acids do not.
And the sulfur is in two amino
acids cystine and methionine.
So you can use those two
tracers for the building blocks.
And the way the
experiment works is
if you've labeled the protein
with sulfur, you infect a cell,
the virus replicates.
And what you're
going to do is then
centrifuge the bacterial cells
to see what's in the cell,
and then you can,
alternatively, label the DNA--
and in this case, I've
shown it as green,
but that would be
the other isotope--
let it infect the cell
and deposit its contents
in the cell, centrifuge
the cells out.
And you want to know where
the radioactivity is,
and the radioactivity
is strictly
associated with phosphorus-32
because the genetic material
that coded for the
production of new baculovirus
is the thing that
stays associated
with the bacterial cell.
In contrast, there's no
radioactivity associated when
you label the cells with S-35.
All right?
Nice experiment.
Easy way to do it.
Rather nice way to do it.
The other experiment I
want to describe to you
very briefly because it
relies on central irrigation
technology that's very powerful.
And it's a method that utilizes
N-15 very, very nicely.
So let me tell you
about that experiment.
There are things
in the laboratory
that we use every
day, ultra centrifuges
and regular centrifuges, that
spin at a very fast speed
where we can really
differentiate things
by molecular mass, which relates
to sedimentation coefficients.
How fast does the particle
spin to the bottom of the tube
when it's under high
centrifugal force?
The heavier it is, the
faster it will spin.
So the question that came
up very early on-- it
looks like a
nonsense question now
because it looks so obvious that
we replicate DNA the way we do.
But originally, it
wasn't absolutely certain
whether DNA was replicated
through a semi-conservative
mechanism, where the
strands came apart
and you made two copies,
a copy of each strand,
to make two identical daughter
new double-stranded DNA.
Alternatively, could you
have a mechanism that
was quite conservative,
you kept your DNA,
and somehow you
made a copy of it.
A little harder for
me to understand.
So your two new
strands, one would
look like the original one, but
one would be very different.
Or dispersive, where you're
just copying bits of the DNA
and somehow reassembling
this gigantic jigsaw puzzle.
The centrifugation
experiment allowed
people to absolutely
and clearly state
that the replication is via
a semi-conservative process.
So let's walk through it.
And what was done is that the
nucleotides within the DNA
were all labeled
with heavy nitrogen.
So for every nucleic acid--
let's say, for
example, when there's
an adenine in the backbone,
there are five nitrogens,
so that would be
five atomic mass
units heavier than nitrogen-14
in that nucleobase.
So N-15 nucleobase, five
mass units heavier than N-14
nucleobase.
Make sense to everybody?
All right.
So it's heavier by some amount.
It's not a massive
amount, but it's
enough to differentiate in
a centrifugation experiment.
So the bacteria were first
grown up in heavy nitrogen,
so all of the DNA sediments
at a certain rate and place.
And it's all got N-15
in it, so it's as heavy
as it can sediment.
And then they let the
bacteria replicate
in the presence of N-14, the
lighter isotope of nitrogen.
And what one would
anticipate to happen
is whenever you
replicate, you peel apart
the two heavy strands, and each
one pairs with a light strand.
So you now have two copies,
two new identical copies of DNA
where half of one strand has
N-15, one strand has N-14.
So it will sediment
less quickly because it
is of a different
density, a lighter
density than the all N-15.
So you would get an
intermediate weight band
in the centrifuge tube
when you're sedimenting.
If you peel those two
strands apart again,
you've got a heavy and a light.
If you're growing
in N-14, the light
will combine with another light,
and there are two of those.
And then the heavy will
combine with a light.
So you'll get new
sedimentation where you still
have a band that's
the combination
of the light and heavy.
But then you start
having some material
that is all of the light.
So this would be this cycle.
So two that are still light
plus heavy, and then two that
are exclusively light.
You keep on
replicating, and you'll
keep on diluting the heavy.
Does that experiment make sense?
It's kind of a cool experiment.
You can hardly
believe it's feasible,
but the centrifugation
ability to differentiate
with these isotopes
is really valuable.
So I just want to put in a
plug for the use of isotopes.
Obviously, they're used
in nuclear physics.
We use a lot of the radioactive
isotopes for different reasons.
But in biology, they are
indispensable for some
of these experiments.
And even to this day,
you can do things
with isotopes you can't by
other experiments, either
the radioactive or the heavy.
There's a great deal of work
done nowadays in proteomics
using mass spectrometry
and heavy isotopes,
where you can really
track where things go
and treat cancer cells
differently from healthy cells,
but actually track
what's happening
by putting heavy isotopes in one
of the growing dishes of cells.
So I like both of those
experiments a lot.
I would put them in the
category of oldies but goodies.
All right.
Now I've got some
details over here
that we've got some explaining
to do as we move forward.
And I just want
to, first of all,
start with a couple
of details that I want
to highlight on this board.
First of all, prokaryotes
such as bacteria, E. Coli,
and eukaryotes such
as human cells.
Have some differences
in their DNA.
So the size of the
bacterial genome
is about five
million base pairs.
The size of the human genome is
not quite 1,000 times bigger,
but a good deal bigger.
The DNA in bacteria is
circular, whereas the DNA
in eukaryotic cells is linear.
And it's actually in the form--
you see all these little images
where you see the pairs of
chromosomes sort of stuck
together at the
center, and that's
linear DNA from one
end to the other.
In bacteria, the
DNA is circular,
so it doesn't have an end.
So they're different, all right?
So replicating circular
DNA is a little bit
different from
replicating linear DNA.
Now in both cases, the
DNA has to be packaged up
so it will fit in the cell.
Otherwise, it's just too
much of a disordered thing.
In the case of bacteria, the
circular DNA is wrapped up
and super coiled
with what are known
as a polyamines, compounds
that are very positively
charged to neutralize all that
negative charge in the DNA.
And in man and other
eukaryotes, the chromosomes
are wrapped around very,
very positively charged
proteins known as histones.
They're similar principles,
but they're different entities.
So when we start talking
about replication
of a prokaryotic cell, here's
the typical circular DNA.
So you can see the
double-stranded DNA.
And I've put a little symbol
here that I call the ORI.
So that's origin of initiation.
So that is the place where
you start copying your DNA.
And we're going
to talk about how
to spot these places
in genomes in a moment.
And so the bacterial genome
is copied bidirectionally,
so you can go in both directions
copying in the appropriate
direction-- we'll talk
about that in a moment--
to make the entire circular DNA
and a perfect copy of the DNA
with bidirectional copying.
And that's not bad
for small genomes
because you've only got
one origin of replication.
You've got to get all the
way around the circular DNA.
It's quite a bit smaller
than the human one.
But what do you do
with gigantic genomes
such as the one that's
about 1,000 times bigger
than the bacterial one?
How do you manage
to still catalyze
the replication of
the entire genome
quickly enough to
make the copy of DNA
in some reasonable
amount of time?
And that is taking
also into consideration
that the speed of
bacterial replication
is 1,000 base pairs per second.
Pretty impressive-- 1,000 of
those bonds made every second--
whereas in eukaryotes,
it sits somewhere down
from 50 base pairs per second,
depending on conditions.
These are not very
explicit numbers.
There's a little
bit of variability.
So how would you do it?
If you had this
massive chunk of gene,
and you've got to copy it just
really pretty quickly in order
to replicate an entire cell
contents in eight hours,
what would you do?
How could you expedite things?
Yeah.
Yes.
So the answer here is start
in a lot of different places
so there's a lot of
collaborative work going
on all along that large genome.
And so when the replication
of the long linear chromosomes
that are in
eukaryotic cells, you
end up with just a lot of
origins of replication.
So you're basically
starting all over the place
so you can get the job
done quickly enough for it
to make sense.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
So start in a lot of places.
It's a pretty easy thing.
All right.
Now I mentioned very briefly
that before you can copy DNA,
you have to unpack it.
Now we think a lot
about packaging DNA,
less about unpacking it.
So I've got these pictures
sort of in a reverse direction.
So it's only this form
of DNA stretched out
that can be copied, whereas
the DNA in your cells
is bundled up very
tightly into chromosomes.
How are they put together?
Those chromosomes are
made up of chromatin,
which is a bunch of balls which
are histone proteins with DNA
wrapped around them.
That's compact chromatin.
Sorry, guys.
Let me go back,
not to go forwards.
So this is chromatin
in a compact form.
This is chromatin now unraveled.
They look more like
beads on a string,
DNA wrapped around
each histone protein
to form those
nucleosomes structures.
And then each nucleosome
looks like this.
It's got protein in the middle
and DNA wrapped around it.
So in order to go
forward and replicate,
we have to unpackage DNA.
There are lots of signals
to unpackage the DNA that we
will talk about later.
The nucleosomes look like this.
So you can trace the DNA and the
proteins bundled in the middle.
And if we have
time at the end, I
will show you the video
of the packaging of DNA
and the video of the
replication of DNA.
They're about a minute
and a half each,
so it's not a whole bunch.
Later on, we will
talk about what
happens when there is a
determination that a cell needs
to replicate its genome.
A bunch of things have
to happen as signals
to do the unwrapping.
And one of those
things is actually
to alter the charged state
of the histone proteins
so you neutralize
the positive charges
so the DNA can unravel for it.
Makes sense.
It's still just a plain old
electrostatic interaction.
So the synthesis
of DNA is what's
known as template-driven
polymerization.
OK.
So template-driven
polymerization.
You'll get a sense of
exactly what that means.
We know the two strands
are complementary,
and we're going to use
one strand as the code
to make a new
complementary strand.
So when we're making DNA,
we have one strand there.
That's what's known as
the template strand.
I want to make a complementary
copy of that strand.
So what the DNA
polymerase is going to do
is systematically
add nucleotides
to the 3 prime OH of the ribose,
and then you keep growing.
But the base that
gets put in is the one
that's complementary to the
base on the template strand.
So if it's thiamine on
the template strand,
it's adenine put in on
the new strand, and so on.
And just to get
these numbers again,
the new strand is grown
from 5 prime to 3 prime.
The old strand is read
3 prime to 5 prime.
So you're reading a strand
and you're reading it 3 to 5,
and you're making 5 to 3.
That's how you end up with
complementary anti-parallel
strands.
OK with that, everyone?
All right.
And when you form
the bond, you go in
with nucleoside triphosphates,
you form a new phosphodiester
with just one of
those phosphoruses,
and you kick out
phosphate phosphate,
which we would call
pyrophosphate or diphosphate.
OK.
So here you could
just sort of see, just
check that you know
what you're doing.
I'm going to just say this is
really a pretty simple thing.
We're going to put in a T,
then we're going to put in an a
then we're going to put in a C
because our template is telling
us to put in the appropriate
purine or pyrimidine that forms
a nice base pair with that.
So there's a question here.
But I've already given
you the answer to it.
So it should be
very straightforward
for you to look at
a template strand
and decide what would be on
the complementary strand,
and also decide on
the directionality
of the complementary strand.
Now origins of replication.
What do they look like?
It's the old where
do I start problem.
Where do I start?
What's the best place to start?
Someone?
Not you.
Anyone else want to answer here?
I've got this whole genome.
I've got to get going.
I've got to start
making a copy of it.
Where's the best place to break
into it to start making copies?
Yeah.
There.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Correct.
It's simple.
It's the difference
between two and three.
If you go to the
area where there's
lots of G's and C's, every
GC has three hydrogen bonds.
If you go to a
different area where
there happen to be a lot
of A's and T's in a row,
each pair is only worth
two hydrogen bonds.
You're going to pick the
stretch that has the most
A's and T's because it's the
place where the base pairing is
weaker.
It's actually very
simple concept.
So it would be
the AT-rich region
is the place where
origins of replication
are more predominant.
OK.
So what we're going to do now--
and this is going to
be tricky, but I'm
going to make this work--
is we're going to
talk about replicating
an entire chunk of gene.
And what I've done here is
I've put the pieces that we're
going to discuss over here.
That's my menu.
And we're going to work
through what we need
to copy a large chunk of DNA.
All right?
Everybody with me?
So I redrew this this morning.
I promised myself
I'm going to be
super tidy on this blackboard,
which is a far stretch for me.
So replication, we know
where replication starts,
AT-rich region.
We could pick those
out in the genome.
We know that we've got to unwind
the DNA to make a copy of it,
so we must have had to
unwrap the DNA beforehand.
These are all known things.
So let's now take a look
at double-stranded DNA
and try and figure out how
we use all the components.
Actually, I'm going to bring
this board down because I
don't see it as well up there.
How do we make use of
all these components
that are part of the
menu that we need
to make the new strand of DNA?
So we have double-stranded
DNA and there are base pairs
across.
That's typical
double-stranded DNA.
That's what we're
starting from, unwrapped.
I haven't made it helical
because my helices will
get messy.
And so we need to start.
So the first thing
that will happen
is that the important
enzymes like the helicase
will scan to find an
origin of replication,
so somewhere for the process
to start because that's where
they're going to break in.
So David, one of your TA's,
works in Steve Bell's lab.
And they study the
mammalian origin
of replication complex,
which is this much more
complicated situation
than what I'm
going to describe to you today.
But they do fabulous
single molecule
work to show how those
pieces are assembled.
But I'll tell you the truth.
As dorky as I am,
the thing that I
find the most cool about the
origin of replication complex
is that it spells ORC.
And if any of you
are Lord of the Rings
fans, who can't be excited by a
complex called the ORC complex?
So there's going
to be the screening
of the genome for ORI.
And I want you to
remember what is up here
is the rest of the chromosome.
It's not just a fuzzy end.
It's something that's
got a lot of stuff
there that's still base paired.
So the first thing
that happens is
that helicase needs
to start unzippering
the double-stranded DNA, so
you get to a new intermediate.
We're going to draw like this.
And the helicase is going to
intercept to basically start
separating those
two strands of DNA
in order to do the replication.
But don't forget that these
are still base paired,
and these now are
single strands.
So I'm going to need
something from that menu.
I'm going to need it quickly.
What do you think's the
next thing we're really
going to need in order to
be able to move forward
in our job?
What do we need from over here?
We're already using the
double-stranded DNA.
It's not going to be too
difficult to figure out
the NTP's.
We're already using the
unzip arrays, the helicase.
What are we going to need?
Yeah.
Primase.
Ah, primase shortly.
But we've really
got to do something
to stabilize our
unzippered stuff.
Anyone else?
So those two single strands
are right near each other,
and they're complementary.
What's going to stop them going
straight back together again
and not allowing replication?
So there are proteins
that basically
sit on the single-stranded
parts of DNA
as are known a single strand
binding proteins that stabilize
this transiently made
complex long enough for it
to be copied.
So so far, we've
used the helicase.
We've used the single
strand binding proteins.
And I'm going to
draw them there,
still remembering that I have
an entire chromosome up here.
Now the heavy lifting
has to start fairly soon,
so we need the
enzyme that's going
to start making a copy of
one of those single strands.
That's going to be a
DNA polymerase, which
is right here.
But DNA polymerase is
kind of a finicky enzyme
because it doesn't
like to just start cold
on the genome, on
the single strand,
and start making a copy.
DNA polymerase needs
a primer of some kind.
So I'm going to just put
that as a note up here.
DNA polymerase needs
what's called a primer.
And what is a primer?
A primer is a sequence--
I think I've got
something up here--
a primer is a sequence that is
complementary to a little bit
of DNA so that when DNA
polymerase comes along,
it's actually grabbing
a double strand
and then filling up the
rest of the single strand.
So this would be a typical
depiction of a primer.
Here's a strand we want to copy.
But the blue one is a primer
strand giving you something
double-stranded to hold onto.
And then in this
situation, DNA polymerase
would be happy to fill in
the rest of the sequence.
So for the purpose of
this discussion to start,
we're just going to
provide a primer that
is complementary to the
DNA just to give us a go.
We have an alternative
in the cell, where
it's to actually use a
primase and RNA building
blocks to build a primer.
But let's keep things
simple for a minute
and get on with a lot
of the major work.
And then we'll come back
to that in a second.
So this part is a primer.
And that primer-- if this
is the 3 prime end, that's
5 prime 3 prime.
So the primer is complementary
to the DNA in that direction.
It's anti-parallel.
And then DNA polymerase can go
along and fill in the strand.
And I'm going to draw
it dashed, and it's
going to keep on growing.
And what I want you to
notice is DNA polymerase
grows from 5 prime to 3 prime.
That is a cardinal
rule, the directionality
that we grow the new DNA in.
So basically, looking
at this picture,
it's going in this direction
because the 3 prime OH is free,
and you're building onto it.
So you use a primer
first, and then you
use DNA polymerase plus deoxy
nucleoside triphosphates.
So all those AT CG
building blocks.
So we've been using these.
We've used the single-stranded
binding proteins.
We've used a primer, but
there are an alternative.
I'll get to that
in just a second.
But we now have a
complex where I'm
going to briefly divert
you to tell you about,
in the cell, what else
you could use as a primer.
And then we're going
to have to deal
with copying this other strand.
But this first
strand that is made
is called the leading strand.
It's the one that's easy.
I peel apart the DNA.
I have a primer there,
and I can just build.
Goes really smoothly.
I'm building in the
right direction.
If you look over on the
other side of the fence,
you've got a problem
because I can't build
on this side from here, right?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yes.
I'd be doing it the
wrong direction.
I would be the
total mess, frankly.
There would be a
crisis in the cell.
So we're going to have
to deal with that.
So let me just get you out
of the primer, just deal
with this primer issue.
In the cell, it's
not like we can micro
inject all these little primers
to get our DNA synthesized.
So RNA polymerase, believe it
or not, doesn't need a primer.
So you can build little
bits of primer with RNA.
You don't build very much,
just build short segments.
And then once you've got
sort of enough there,
DNA polymerase can
start polymerizing.
So you use RNA polymerase and
nucleoside triphosphates, not
the deoxy ones.
So later on, we've
got this piece here
that might be made
deoxy RNA, which is why,
coming over here to my menu--
do I have it?
Yes.
We need an RNA
primase, and we need
RNA's to chop them out so that
DNA polymerase can come back
because now there is
double-stranded material
and fill in the gap.
And then we need one more enzyme
to stitch together the gaps.
And that's the ligase.
The logic of this
stuff is great.
I think it's just really
amazing because all these moving
parts have evolved to make
all these functions fall
into place.
Now we need to talk about
this pesky other strand.
So we have a problem
here because we've
got the wrong directionality.
So what happens in nature
is as soon as there's
enough of a stretch, a
primer is put in place,
growing the DNA in
the right direction.
That's from where the
helicase is unzipping.
So we put in another primer.
And then DNA polymerase--
that's the white one--
can build its
complementary strand,
building in the appropriate
direction to be consistent.
So you basically fill
in a chunk and then
you have to wait awhile
till more is unzippered,
put in another primer,
and then grow the DNA.
So in that other piece you're
making little segments of DNA
intervened by RNA primers.
Later on, those small primers
are going to be chewed up
by RNA's.
DNA polymerase is
going to fill them in,
and ligase is
going to join them.
Does that make sense?
It's a lot to grasp.
And this other side
is called what's
known as the lagging strand.
And there are
pieces of short DNA
that are transiently made
that have their own name.
You can remember it or not.
I just feel I'm not
being complete if I
don't mention their name.
They're called Okazaki
fragments after the guy
who discovered them.
And they're longer in
bacteria than in humans.
So Okazaki fragments are the
transient short stretches
of DNA that are made
in the lagging strand,
and then they get
zipped together.
So that's sort of the story
for replicating the DNA.
Let me make sure I've
described everything to you.
Leading strand, lagging strand.
Oh, can't believe I
almost forgot this.
All right.
Now we got a problem.
So we've come all this way.
We've used all the pieces.
We haven't used
one of the pieces.
So we're in a small
bit of trouble
because what's going to happen
when you're, for example,
trying to peel apart your DNA?
What trouble are you
going to run into?
Who wants to come up here
and get involved in my demo?
And you've got to be aware that
you're going to be on screen.
You and you up there.
You've got your hand up first.
OK.
I need someone who's
going to hold onto this as
if their life depends on it.
You can't let the
yellow ones slip out.
So you are the rest
of the chromosome,
so make sure that you
really hold-- and you
don't let things come apart.
Now you are helicase, OK?
OK.
So come on.
Start helicasing and really
pull as hard as you can.
He's going to hold it.
No, I don't want you to
unwind it because we're
in the middle of a chromosome.
So you've literally got
to do what helicase does.
Yeah, keep on pulling.
Come on, you can do it.
Can you go much further?
I mean, your arms
aren't any longer.
But it's almost
impossible, right?
We get to a stage
where we need help.
The help we have coming
is from topoisomerase.
Topoisomerase does something--
so walk just one step this way.
Yeah.
Topoisomerase some comes
along and it cuts the DNA.
It holds the pieces in
its hands, if you will,
lets the super coiling
relax, and then it
joins them back again.
So topoisomerase-- thank
you very much, guys.
That's it.
Chromosome, helicase, thank you.
We really have some
tightly wound DNA here.
So topoisomerase is the get out
of jail free card because it
allows you to deal with all of
this tension you got in place
that you cannot unravel.
So you need someone who is
literally going to cut, hold,
let the thing relax, rejoin it.
And there are some
topoisomerases
called DNA gyrases.
But the really cool
thing about topoisomerase
is that it's a
wonderful drug target
in both mammalian
and bacterial cells
because they're quite different
in the two types of organisms.
So in bacteria the
antibiotic ciprofloxacin
is a topoisomerase
inhibitor that
actually stops your bacteria
dividing because if topo
doesn't work, you can't go on.
And in human biology
and cancer biology,
there are also topoisomerases--
there's one called
[INAUDIBLE] --
that does the same thing in
the eukaryotic topoisomerase
to stop cancer cells dividing
rapidly so that those cannot go
on and make larger tumors.
So I want to show you something.
And I am actually
certain that I have time.
Come on.
Now I'm going to show you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In this animation, we'll
see the remarkable way
our DNA is tightly
packed up so that six
feet of this long molecule fits
into the microscopic nucleus
of every cell.
The process starts when DNA is
wrapped around special protein
molecules called histones.
The combined loop of DNA and
protein is called a nucleosome.
Next, the nucleosomes are
packaged into a thread.
The end result is a
fiber known as chromatin.
This fiber is then looped
and coiled yet again,
leading finally to the
familiar shapes known
as chromosomes, which can be
seen in the nucleus of dividing
cells.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Now I'm going
to take you forward to DNA,
what we just talked about here.
- Using computer animation
based on molecular research,
we are now able to see
how DNA is actually
copied in living cells.
You are looking at
an assembly line
of amazing miniature biochemical
machines that are pulling apart
the DNA double helix
and cranking out
a copy of each strand.
The DNA to be copied
enters the production line
from bottom left.
The whirling blue molecular
machine is called helicase.
It spins the DNA as
fast as a jet engine
as it unwinds the double
helix into two strands.
One strand is
copied continuously
and can be seen spooling
off to the right.
Things are not so simple
for the other strand
because it must be
copied backwards.
It is drawn out
repeatedly in loops
and copied one
section at a time.
The end result is two
new DNA molecules.
[END PLAYBACK]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: All right.
OK.
That's what you saw
today, replication,
a lot of the mechanics, a
lot of the moving parts.
There's this tricky
stuff with primers.
You'll get used to that.
But this is really
the quintessential set
of pieces to replicate DNA.
It is an amazing process.
Look at the speed.
1,000 base pairs a second.
Can you even believe it?
An entire circular chromosome
copied in 20 minutes.
So these are really
things to think about
because they are so impressive
that it's a delight to actually
be able to teach them to you.
OK.
I'm done for today.